Gemüse ist gesund,
aber wie ist es gesünder:
roh oder gekocht?
* Musik *
Eisvogel hat uns gefragt:
Gehen Vitamine beim Kochen kaputt?
Sehr gute Frage.
Gleich erst mal:
Warum kochen wir überhaupt?
Sagen wir so,
wir Menschen
sind mit relativ kleinen Zähnen,
verhältnismäßig
schwachen Kiefern
und keinem besonders starken
Verdauungssystem ausgestattet.
Wenn wir nicht durch kochen
Cellulose oder Fleischfasern auf-
weichen würden, dann würde uns das
viel zu viel Energie
beim Kauen und Verdauen kosten.
Das "Foodkoma"
hätte eine neue Dimension.
Viele glauben, dass Gemüse
roh gesünder ist als gekocht.
Aber, was sagt
eigentlich die Wissenschaft dazu?
Es gehen wirklich Vitamine und
Antioxidantien beim Kochen kaputt.
Vitamin C zum Beispiel
überlebt kochen nur teilweise.
Tomaten zum Beispiel
verlieren nach zwei Minuten kochen
etwa 10 % Vitamin C,
nach einer halben Stunde sind
es etwa 30 %, die verloren gehen.
Auch die sogenannten Polyphenole,
die in vielen Gemüsesorten vorkommen
und das Risiko für Krebs und
Herz-Kreislauf-Erkrankungen senken,
verlieren beim Kochen
ihre anti-oxidative Wirkung.
Und auch Brokkoli
ist roh gesünder als gekocht.
Aber isst irgendjemand Brokkoli roh?
Jedenfalls
zerstört die Hitze ein Enzym,
das Brokkoli
Anti-Krebs-Wirkungen verleiht.
Soweit gute Nachrichten für alle,
die nicht gern kochen.
Hey Melanie,
so manches Gemüse wird durchs Kochen
für uns tatsächlich
nährstoffreicher.
Die Hitze zersetzt nämlich
die robusten Zellwände der Pflanzen
und macht so Nährstoffe frei,
die sonst
an diese Zellwänden gebunden sind.
Nehmen wir das Beispiel Möhren.
Hier erhöht kochen
den Gehalt von Beta-Carotin,
was in Vitamin A umgewandelt wird,
und auch den Gehalt von Lycopin.
Lycopin ist wie Beta-Carotin
auch ein roter Farbstoff.
Er kommt v.a. in Tomaten vor,
in Wassermelonen, in Paprika
und wird mit einem verminderten
Risiko für Krebs und Herzinfarkt
in Verbindung gebracht.
Manche Forscher sehen in Lycopin
sogar einen stärkeres Antioxidanz
als in Vitamin C.
Da Vitamin C
häufiger in Obst vorkommt,
was wir eh roh essen,
und Lycopin häufiger in Gemüse,
das wir eben kochen,
ist die Kombination
von Obst und Gemüse eine gute Sache.
Wie eure Mama
schon immer gesagt hat.
Neben Möhren geben uns auch Spinat,
Pilze, Spargel, Kohl oder auch
Paprika insgesamt mehr Nährstoffe,
wenn man sie kocht oder gart.
Gemüse braten und v.a. frittieren,
ist, wer hätte das gedacht,
leider nicht so gesund.
Nicht nur wegen des Fettgehaltes,
sondern auch, weil beim Frittieren
das Öl ständig oxidiert wird
und dabei freie Radikale entstehen.
Freie Radikale
sind nicht nur schädlich,
sondern brauchen auch die ganzen
Antioxidantien aus dem Gemüse auf,
die dann nicht mehr
für uns übrig bleiben.
Es gibt sehr viele Forschung dazu,
ich könnte jetzt
noch viele Studien aufzählen,
die die Vorteile von
gekochtem Gemüse untersucht haben.
Am Ende ist nur wichtig:
Gemüse ist gesund.
Und wenn wir es so zubereiten,
dass es uns besser schmeckt,
dann essen wir
natürlich auch mehr davon.
Und das ist die Hauptsache.
Schön schlau.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Vielen Dank Eisvogel
für deine schönschlaue Frage!
Wenn ihr noch Fragen habt,
schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Und lasst mich bitte wissen,
was ihr denkt,
was auf meinem T-Shirt drauf ist.
Ist das für euch ein Kaktus?
Oder ein Brokkoli?
Oder was ganz anderes?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare,
bis demnächst!